ich habe in deiner übrigens rein
gespuckt das macht nix ist habe ich
nicht gesehen
nein spaß und der liefert bestimmt denn
deine minister extra mal gucken was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen bei anderen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut ich habe heute den pascal doubai
was geht ich weiß nicht also
wahrscheinlich die meisten die jetzt
dieses video schauen haben auch schon
den block mit dir gesehen aber trotzdem
kannst du dich auch für die anderen die
ich jetzt zwar nicht kennen mal ganz
kurz vorstellen wer du bist und was wir
heute vorhaben vielleicht ich habe heute
mal den alex versuchte durch besuche mal
den atx und wollte mal so einen kleinen
essen die challenger und wer vielleicht
schon im ersten video gesehen habt also
ich bin komplett sind und wir wollten
mal schauen wer von uns besser essen
kann genau
also wir haben gerade essen bestellt
einmal pizza spaghetti und noch
nachtisch und auch was zu trinken
also irgendwie wird es ein bisschen
ungesund heute aber seid ja von mir
gewohnt das ganze war die idee von
pascal und zwar hat er gesagt ja ich
immer wenn ich esse ich sehe dabei nicht
mal schauen wie das bei dir ist wenn du
nicht siehst also wir essen jetzt gleich
diese gerichte hintereinander
das lustige ist wir haben bestellt bei
der ersten pizzeria bei der wir bestellt
haben die wahl heutigen wie gar nicht
offen da habe ich nach 15 minuten darin
nachricht bekommen ja irgendwie konnte
pizzeria nicht erreicht werden leider
motive sharon storniert bei der zweiten
wo ich gerade bestellt habe fehlen
einfach nudeln die kommen jetzt gleich
noch nach
und wir haben heute schon ziemlich viel
fläche und wir schauen mal wieder an
mein teller aussieht was ist dein talent
wir aufgegessen haben natürlich erstmal
mit besteck also nicht mit handeln das
ganz wichtig oder die bezahlung besteht
besteht genau und wo dann halt so die
unterschiede sind weil du solltest jaja
perfektionist drin sein eigentlich und
ich halte ich weiß ich bin mir spaß ich
will gar nicht so viel aber wir fangen
mit der pizza an dann habe ich das
gesagt ich rede mal so viel
also ich habe jetzt hier mit einem t
shirt ungebunden ich sehe halt wirklich
absolut ghana ich nehme diese mütze
das deutlich bessere sicherheit nicht
kommen und gar nichts mehr und ich sehe
glaube ich getan habe war das bankräuber
ist jedes mal ist das okay ich bin
bereit und wir dann lassen wir
angefangen hast du mein messer gesehen
aber ich hoffe dass ich beherrsche und
ist schon schwierig und so hast du schön
stück ich nicht sagt hat immer das habe
ich mir leichter vorgestellt
weil ganze pizza zuschneiden dass auch
es mich dafür von katar song ganz
kleines käse stück
[Musik]
wenn man jedoch kein stück war jetzt
jetzt nicht ist und dort hat hamann ich
hab so wunder da drauf jetzt in diesem
scheiss pizza geb ich warte hier ist er
an
hier steht jetzt rein zur ersten film
ändern soll was hast du keine stück auf
diesen zeugen habe wieder bei dir gerade
die aber ihre mittel alleine ist es ist
ein stück käse oder so abgelenkt sodass
jetzt ahnt es ist schon ein anderes sein
wird
[Musik]
solistisch schneiden das ist so
schwierig ist hätte ich niemals gedacht
ich glaube meine spitzer sie daraus wie
bombenanschlag ist irgendwie falsch rum
jetzt glaube ich musste nachher nummern
zu erzählen das angucken und sagen was
du selbst überlegen aber jetzt habe ich
das meine pizza falsch rum den tisch wie
weit bist du denn so ein viertel also
wird zeigen und bei dir ist dir das so
komplett geradeaus fliegen wie madsen
ist also ich habe mir das war ein posten
bei mir das also ich habe angefangen zu
schalten und dann ja aber ich habe diese
extra sucht zu finden aber ich hab's
nicht getroffen
ich habe mir die pizza hut erst so
gedreht dass ich ja sie kann
von hagens abzuschneiden dann immer so
spricht kurz mit der hand präsentieren
das kannst du machen dass es dann
manchmal sogar den fingerspitzen zur
ecke des die zweite hälfte wurde ist
heute die andere die anderen hinter
gesamte nacht in einigen punkten wie das
aussieht deshalb der zunahme der gemacht
das war super dafür plagt ist nicht
schlimm kommen jetzt noch zwei geschenke
bekommen weil die jetzt eben vergessen
haben das war freundlich der typ ist das
hast du bist hast du bekommen
pizzabrötchen und irgendwie so
fassbrause hast du ja gut heute
vergleicht mal diese täler mit diesem
thema
also du hast noch keinen du hast jetzt
absolut doch das ist ungefähr die hälfte
davon hier meinen teller bei mir ist der
ganze käse abgeflogen
jetzt würde ich gleich mal bei den
nudeln gucken ob ich da besser kann was
uns jetzt erstmal darf ich ohne ohne
augenbinde weiter essen neben ihren
kannst machen weil ich glaube sonst wird
das nix einer pizza habe ich schon mal
richtig verpackt ich habe wirklich ich
habe glaube ich ein stück geschafft und
von dem rest habe ich automatisch den
käse runtergezogen
guck mal wie das aussieht um einen
teller um das ist alles voll mit so
tomaten zweig und jetzt machen wir heute
mit der nächsten runde als nächstes
stehen nun an jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ich glaube dass krieg besser hin und
werden es auch gesagt wir schütten dass
ich noch etwas zu trinken oder willst du
anfangen und getränken fangen wir mal
erst dann hast du alles nutzen
ich guck mal kurz
zwar nicht gefährdet sind muss noch mit
dem finger
natürlich bin läuft da was zu trinken
ein
was du je stück das muss irgendwie
vorstellen aber nicht hervor mir ist
lustig ich habe dort 140 zentimeter für
zentimeter perfekt sagt constance sein
also es ist nicht ganz voll weil es
wieder runter scheint aber das war genau
bis zum rand jetzt ist es wieder so zwei
dritteln oder so noch nein ich glaube
ist eingetroffen
oder darf ich kurz gucken es ist auf
jeden fall über gelaufen also
meinetwegen kann man starten
guten appetit ich habe ich erst nur dann
auch mal mit einer gabel wo es aber das
ist jetzt glaube ich schon auf jeden
fall einfacher irgendwie so gesehen also
pizzaschneider setzen macht man ja auch
ein
[Musik]
das ist eine richtig gute pizzeria leute
auf tschuldigung natürlich auch bei mir
ich kann halt nichts machen also ich
würde schon gerne anders machen aber ich
bin nicht ich glaube beim einen
spaghetti sind jetzt so ein bisschen ist
um so ein bisschen cooler mit dran aber
ich bin mir auch nicht sicher weil ich
habe es nicht gesehen schmeckt sind
meine ich habe deine übrigens rein
gespuckt
das macht nichts habe ich nicht gesehen
und der liefert bestimmt denn deine
minister extrakt normal kommt deswegen
hat er sich gefreut und in der 8 hier
hast du noch ein getränk das die
colaflasche noch irgendwann tun also bei
mir clubs richtig gut stark ein problem
ich kann mich daran gewöhnen und was ich
eben auch schon gesagt habe da war die
kamera aus deinem vorteil ist ja wenn
etwas eklig aussieht aber richtig gut
schmeckt ist es ja
wenn du merkst du weißt du gar nicht ob
es wirklich ausgesehen haben manchmal
denke ich mir so wahre alter sieht das
täglich aus eines problems wenigstens
kann probiert gar nicht also ich kann
natürlich so fange ich wieder die mit
saftig gut obwohl ich das nicht von
meinen dort kann dann ist alles schief
gehen oder
leute ihr könnt ja gerne in die
kommentare schreiben weil wir hatten
eben bei ihm darüber gesprochen er hat
auch mal irgendwie darüber nachgedacht
in einem youtube kanal zu erstellen
ob ihr das cool findet dann schreibt man
die kommentare hashtag single #bv10 #bpw
unfall das ist gut herr scheck einfach
und mal weil ich hatte hier glaube ich
schon einige unfälle also ich bin bei
dir jetzt aber wirklich besser aus als
wenn es bei mir ist es so soll verteilt
immer im keller und wir leben ist halt
anders von kohle und meine haare sind
jetzt scheint wegen der mütze
dann lasse ich einfach auch wenn wir den
abstieg auch noch essen schon heute aber
wenn man so fitness machen muss ob ihren
kalorien muss sonntag kommt es gerade
einmal wie es hier aussieht
er sagt gerade wenn man das getränk
geschüttet dass man den finger rein tut
dann habe ich gar nicht gedacht ich habe
einfach so nach gefühl das ist halt
einfacher so weit so getränken wird das
cola die halt total wasser so kann man
es auch mal gehören oder bei saft aber
wir machen jetzt mal eine kleine
challenge und zwar versuchte jetzt mal
hier die fassbrause die wir noch dazu
geschenkt bekommen haben auch kannst du
dich auch selber auch mal mit sondern
wenn ich eine flasche kann zudem gemacht
hast du flaschenöffner ja hier mit der
flasche kannst du das du kannst jetzt
lasse ich mal nicht dran nur nach gehör
bis jetzt ist er voll rechte hälfte des
gt das ganze rein na ja fast um das ist
0,3 liter glas und hier ist 0,33 drin ja
gut ab ich weiß nicht das tiramisu das
muss ich mir jetzt nicht auch ein
pfeifen wie gesagt ihr habt es gesehen
es ist wirklich sehr sehr schwierig und
man muss sich richtig dran gewöhnen dass
ich habe da richtig respekt vor wenn man
das halt also wenn man eine pizza so
schneiden kann und die perfekt ist also
leute hier
es war nicht mein platz an wie sieht's
aus ansonsten würde ich sagen das war's
mit dem video falls ihr das video von
gestern noch vor wissen was wir gedreht
haben noch nicht gesehen habe zeigt dass
auf jeden fall ab schaut gern mal bei
pascal beij insel vorbei oder so soll
ihr in unseren armen in die kommentare
packen oder blendet er ein wenn ich hier
ein und wir sehen uns am morgen mainz
nur wieder dann bis zu schauen
machs gut sie das nächste mal